[Music]
it's sex ed Neil yeah submitted by
lights camera action I'd like you
participate - thank you ready - he's all
row at a stand up and you're excited
yeah and oh my god never been here
before
oh he said my name oh he says I iced up
[ __ ] that's a deal one you guys a
good comic here are ten answers to sex
questions you might be too embarrassed
to ask not my wife is Li on the first
day don't be embarrassed to ask that you
want to get pegged in abajo no I think
like what is Peggy how do you put out a
condom or something like that no no are
not that basic but they are mark to me
they seem like very like muta sex kind
of these are for people who read Yahoo
News where they're embarrassed because
of their lack of knowledge Oh where's
the clip because it's a fetish but
because like everyone should know this
yeah kind of thing how do you think
there's somebody where's the g-spot no
no those are those are too advanced okay
how do I relax my [ __ ]
it's just for 16 year olds that was just
a question how do I get my boner to go
away during class you always think of
Grandma no you let me just tell you the
first one and this is for both men and
few notes of it you're trying to peek
the first one says I can never have an
orgasm during sex is there something
wrong with me
you can't come but a guy or girl I feel
like this could be for both mm-hmm no
but then this one seems like it's more
about women yeah so then this says
because porn makes it seem like women
come every single time exactly what it
says often shows women having an orgasm
immediately after having penetrative sex
but for many people with vaginas orgasms
yeah require more than just penetration
the vast majority of women can't orgasm
because most of most women need clitoral
stimulation to reach orgasm there is a
small percentage of women though that
have never experienced or even period
yeah yeah I'm a date you
hey Joey give me one it's like it it's
like psychological or something like you
can't get there because they're personal
yeah yeah well vaginally it's hard for a
lot of women have to have orgasms during
sex because it's also to do with the
dick shape like the penis has to
consistently hit that g-spot which is in
you know a place that and not all dicks
are shaped that way and they have to do
it consistently until the woman comes so
if there's so many factors one shape to
the consistency three the pace of it the
letting go we just found out that
Nikki's vagina tilts to the left I think
oh my uterus your uterus to life
not even my gyno Avenue gyno and she did
an ultrasound on my uterus which I even
know that they did that but I recently
did one yeah yeah for my ovaries oh yeah
for my over like an overactive
overeating it really hurt oh [ __ ] yeah
well apparently I got a lot of really
fertile eggs in there well yeah and it
leans to left so now I hit I hit a
question what is the anatomy of a
woman's right that's Steve's quite
simple I would like to know the other
people the same thing great so are these
questions that you don't want to ask
yeah like you're too embarrassed to
embarrass ass because you think that
means wrong questions are being asked by
a gynecologist and a sex therapist
second question here it's I can't have
an orgasm during sex but I know how to
give one to myself how can I direct my
partner to help me orgasm well that's
the same kind of question yeah more
clitoral than vaginal also I was reading
that and I don't know people I don't
know everything but I was just reading
this article that um as women get older
like in their mid to late 30s they have
more vaginal orgasms so I'm really
looking forward to that vaginal orgasm
like g-spot one yeah yeah
dang so just like picks up or something
I don't know I just I was reading
something maybe because like older women
become less self-conscious I really do
think it's a huge mental thing
yeah so you just always thinking I have
to come I have to come I have to come
life to come where I should come you
don't let the of women I've been with
like a very few handful but from what
I've experienced like the girls who were
a lot more relaxed and more comfortable
it was easier for them versus the ones
that felt pressure that they had that's
true we feel pressure because our
partner really wants to make us come and
they feel like they failed if they did
it well I don't feel like I feel at all
that's right feel like oh yeah it feels
nice it feels like I we had dinner
together and then I dined and dashed and
you know I had a great time it was great
and I genuinely tried if I couldn't
succeed well I got a B+ that's all I got
it to this question here though this sex
therapist and kind of call use they were
saying that the best step is to teach
your partner how to help you orgasm with
their hands so like you play with
yourself and then they could put your
their hand on top of your hand and then
you can tell them what it is that you're
doing and then they can do commuting yes
communication is a big thing and I think
I just did like not about this but it's
like where people talk about how they
think that there's like a specific code
for every girl and it's not the case
it's about talking to the person knowing
what they like and then you adjust and
sometimes you gotta experiment too cuz
they don't know exactly like your one
little dick move that you've been doing
isn't gonna work for every [ __ ]
person yeah but when you think that you
own [ __ ] my favorite guys know that's
when you just copy/paste your one though
that you did in your high school
girlfriend that you think they liked you
now you're the [ __ ] forever every single
girl has been just stroking your ego
it's like you think that you're a
locksmith because you have one key that
works in your one home long exact you
think it works every what
it's like yo how come the tornado didn't
work on you you call it the tornado the
cyclone the cyclone gonna work yeah I
mean thing goes for like girls with guys
right guys are a lot of not really same
exact motion same exact technique you
know not really I can [ __ ] I think
for the most part it's it's not that
hard to figure out I mean like wow look
at Warren well it's not about figuring
out cuz at least like from my experience
it's like one person likes one thing
more than the other person would yeah so
it's like figuring out what I think it's
more like this it's it's it's more
preferential when it comes to [ __ ]
and hand jobs but the vagina is a great
vagina
once we pump it it's gonna squirt but
the head and the mouth are as a
different story because hand jobs are
really hard I think for a girl to get
right unless you communicate you know
unless a guy actually told the girl hey
I don't like it like that I you should
do it like this cuz the girls don't have
a dick so how the [ __ ] would they know
how we would like in so unless you
really told somebody it's not gonna
really adjust same thing with the
[ __ ] too if you just put your mouth
on it's like whatever like [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
yeah and I feel like mm-hmm don't have
to do much well Steve I suppose in most
cases really cuz it feels like a lot of
work weight doesn't feel like it's all
huh no he says we don't to do much could
tell you otherwise like we think about
it right like you don't you don't know
how to work yeah they do much but then
you're on your back and that's kind of
nice alright next question right guys
could make themself come like all you
got to do is just like lay there I could
look at a beanbag kind of jiggle in a
comma right next question
yeah why does it sound like I'm party
for my vagina during sex so I guess like
a lot of people don't know this but it's
called the queef that happens when
you're pumping during sex or pumping air
inside the vagina and then it's gonna is
this like people like Polish people like
[ __ ] you that's insane like this is
gonna like beginner this is for
seventh-day adventists but it might be
also why people are embarrassed to ask
cuz they know it sounds beginner II
probably so the good reason why we're
talking about this I think you should be
tall girls is can a penis break hmm
technically kind of yes because it's a
rupture you can have a rupture of a
penis you would tear the sponge or you
could even
what's it called the the urethra
actually care you're the [ __ ] Jane is
where a guy broke his dick yeah it's now
that's like one of the things I I like
real life you read we were doing a stew
feels it was like a big wake-up call to
me like to see how many people are not
like open and honest in relationships or
like they can't communicate certain
things and I was like why cuz not
everyone's the same
and people are embarrassed for certain
things or there's - self-conscious like
even married couples are like I don't
know it's just like wow it's cuz we're
raised in a society that teaches that
sex is some bad and like that it should
be covered up in some way and not like
openly like yo it's cool that it's okay
to talk about this like my parents
sheltered us from sex and it just made
me more interested in what the [ __ ] was
going on but if you already had sex with
them wouldn't that I don't know that's
like my icebreaker after I have sex with
someone like at that point I could say
whatever extroverted right so I think a
lot of people they'll have sex with
somebody but they're more like meek
about the way that they feel about
things
and so they need to they need to feel
really comfortable and really like
they're not gonna be judged like to say
what they the boner will top it yeah I
don't know if this like a case I mean
this is obviously mine's very anecdotal
but like Asian women that I have been
sexually active with tend to have been
more demure and they were they just
didn't communicate very well you know
what it means so if I ask them what do
you like what do you not like I don't
even know they don't know or they feel
really weird or if we were comfort zone
yeah it has to do with like how the
household is to the lady or whatever yes
they're Agdal for me but that's you know
I've been with majority Asian women so
when when I experienced that it was
always so weird for me because I never
knew what to [ __ ] do I didn't know
cuz nobody would tell me mm-hmm
and it took for a freak ass [ __ ]
Philip to grow the [ __ ] you know
really like hey I don't like this I
don't like that do it this way do it
that way it's always the Filipino girls
I teach you all that [ __ ]
it roasted my ass dude okay hurt my
feelings I was like what [ __ ] do that
then I will say right now for the record
that is definitely an Asian thing you
know Filipino why cuz he did it other
Asians
mr. Filipino Filipinos are different
though but I always say it's not an
Asian thing right so I'm just I'm just
connecting it to that the Filipinos are
like that oh yeah well I'm right away
I'm like go lower no heart no softer
lower to left side easier to so like
well then I realize oh that's not a good
thing they don't like this they don't
like that because like general truths
and then there's like specific things
that's to that person yeah
so until her she was the one that
actually was like oh [ __ ] I should ask
these questions
I should like figuring it out you know
cuz she was so [ __ ] straightforward
just good I think she had a lot of sex
and that's how she communicated her
affection it was through physical touch
yeah cuz once you get it right it's like
yes you that's what you want free yeah
he's like a spy and she's telling me how
to bomb the target yeah and it's really
helpful yeah I literally asked okay no
it's time to [ __ ] it's going yeah so you
guys don't know the rest of these
questions and answers you check out the
link in the description it was
anticlimactic for a sex thing yeah
[Music]